le numéro de reporter sur france24
direction la principauté d'andorre micro
état au coeur des pyrénées entre la
france et l'espagne le territoire visité
chaque année par des milliers de
touristes est connu pour ses pistes de
ski ses magasins d'alcool et de
cigarettes détaxées est un secteur
financier florissant qui contribue
beaucoup à l'image de paradis fiscal
mais dans le reportage que nous vous
présentons vous allez découvrir une
autre image d'anders avec nous lors à
cambo bonjour laura vous avez passé
plusieurs semaines dans ce dans ce micro
état ultra moderne qui repose en réalité
sur des institutions datant du moyen-âge
c'est donc l'une des plus vieilles
démocraties au monde et ils en sont très
fiers à andorre mais elle est
aujourd'hui la cible de critiques
notamment sur les questions du droit des
femmes il faut dire que l'un des co
prince d'andorre et l'évêque d'urgell
qui est une ville ans en espagne voisine
et que ses positions sur l'avortement
sont intangibles alors absolument tout
d'abord l'andorre a été fondée en 780
elle repose sur un contrat de droit
féodal comme vous l'expliqué qui concède
le trône à deux co-princes donc lancé le
président de la république française
avant cet endroit est aujourd'hui c'est
l'évêque d'urgell qui habite donc en
catalogne et qui est soumis aux ordres
du vatican depuis une constitution a été
écrite un parlement été créés en
gouvernement est même nommé mais leur
rôle reste le même en principe ils ne
doivent pas s'impliquer dans la vie
politique de l'andorre dans les affaires
courantes mais vous allez le voir dans
ce reportage les institutions entrave
clairement les droits des femmes dans la
principauté reportage de laura cambo et
léa caboche
[Musique]
en andorre
vanessa mendoza cortes est un symbole
cette femme de 41 ans risque plusieurs
années de prison pour avoir dénoncé à
l'onu la criminalisation de l'avortement
dans la principauté
ils nous ont invités pour parler des
droits des femmes en andorre
on installerait bonjour à tous que la
jeune
marie comme tout le monde et à l'andorre
est un état féodal comme tout et tout
fut contrainte chaud c'est difficile et
honteux pour nous les femmes et les
féministes de devoir lutter pour des
droits basiques comme l'avortement poche
pour cette dénonciation vanessa est
poursuivi pour diffamation et atteinte à
la nation
et je risque jusqu'à 4 ans en prison
peut-être que je n'irai pas mais je
risque aussi de payer une amende de 5000
euros ce qui n'est pas possible c'est
qu'on dise à la moitié de la population
qu'on ne peut pas obtenir nos droits car
un monsieur croire un dogme et que si on
obtient au droit il menace d'appliquer
à partir du moment où on est gouverné
par un homme d'église ce n'est plus une
démocratie c'est une théocratie
l'andorre est aujourd'hui un
anachronisme
elle est dirigée par deux co princes
depuis le moyen âge le président de la
république française et l'évêque
d'urgell
bienvenue à tous
il est le garant des institutions et son
influence est considérable mais il ne
s'exprime jamais dans les médias
schwantz multi touch nous pouvons
construire un futur pour l'andorre avec
la paix la stabilité
et la croissance économique dopée mais
aussi en conservant nos valeurs
spirituelles et culturelles
du coup tous les noms parmi ces valeurs
le droit à la vie l'évêque imposent une
ligne rouge l'interdiction absolue
d'avorter
l'association de vanessa aidé des
centaines de femmes armées témoigner
publiquement est ici impossible
cette jeune andorrane accepte de nous
parler à condition d'être totalement
anonyme
que tu n'es pas face au problème
l'andorre ne semble pas si mal mais
c'est encore mieux si tu grandis dans ce
cocon
bon bah ce n'est pas si mal
mais après si tu dois faire face à
certaines choses c'est qu'apple tu te
dis mais je suis en europe gd droit
européen j'ai accès aux infrastructures
des pays voisins comme au détail
pourquoi est ce que ça représente pour
moi un tel obstacle à chaud je passe au
projet enquête
obstacle l'air
en andorre il y environ 70 médecins
aucun d'eux ne peut pratiquer
d'avortements légalement
bonjour méric sylvestre de lsa est l'un
des rares qui acceptent de prendre
position pour liv et g
voilà donc dans la salle d'attenté j'ai
affiché depuis environ 2007 le manifeste
pour le droit à l'avortement
plus que symbolique ça a permis au
niveau relation patient médecin de
libérer la parole
libéré la parole mais selon le code
pénal pratiquer un avortement reste un
crime pour un médecin
doit être puni d'une peine de prison de
3 mois à 3 ans et d'une habilitation
exercer
quelques professions sanitaires pour une
période jusqu'à cinq ans aucune
exception n'est permise même en cas de
viol ou de danger pour la vie de la mère
ou de l'enfant
en cas de malformation foetale non
viable est obligé de continuer une
grossesse en théorie du moins
jusqu'à jusqu'à la mort du foetus
il y a deux ans le gouvernement
d'andorre a créé plusieurs centres
d'accueil comme celui ci visite avec la
ministre des affaires sociales et
jacques c'est dans cette salle
elles viennent ici parlent de leurs
problèmes de leurs inquiétudes de leurs
doutes nous sommes là pour y répondre
et gagnent dans la khl une écoute qui se
terminent toujours de la même façon une
invitation à aller avorter ailleurs
mais ces centres ne sont ils pas
hypocrite
biographie je crois qu'il n'ya pas
d'hypocrisie
c'est notre constitution c'est notre
code pénal c'est clair personne ne se
cache vous êtes venus ici pour nous
interviewer dans un centre où on informe
les femmes des options qu'elles ont et
elles peuvent venir en toute sécurité en
toute liberté mais on ne donne pas des
aides pour financer l'avortement brrr
sinon il y aurait une contradiction avec
la loi la lectio à avalanches la game
non
[Musique]
la plupart des andorrane prennent la
direction de barcelone à trois heures de
route là bas l'intervention coûte entre
300 et 2000 euros
coincé au coeur des pyrénées les quatre
vingt mille habitants d'andorre ont les
mêmes institutions depuis 700 ans
alors subi style ce conservatisme ou
soit il un changement
il faut que ça devienne un pays civilisé
on a un co prince catholique qui ça rend
tous très compliqué
c'est un archaïsme
en fait tout dépend des institutions qui
se sont maintenues traditionnellement et
qui ont donné une stabilité au pays
culturellement c'est une population très
traditionnel très fermée sur elle même
très catholique
ici 90% de la population est catholique
alors le dimanche pour les fidèles
passage obligé par la basilique notre
dame de meritxell la sainte patronne
d'andorre
le vent nous et rendons grâce à dieu
ramon rosell officie dans cette paroisse
depuis 55 ans
instaurée en fait depuis charlemagne
l'andorre a été confiée à l'évêque
d'urgell
et puis il endort et très rural il ya
toujours les traditions de célébrer la
saint-antoine la saint sébastien
la saint-vincent et c'est donc on est
très très chrétien pour le client
cette tradition chrétienne sont défendus
par le parlement qui existe depuis 1400
josep pinta tête un député conservateur
il est aussi membre de l'une des dix
familles les plus influentes du pays
on va assister à une séance
parlementaire une séance de contrôle du
gouvernement
le père est le cousin de josep pinta tu
ont tous les deux été premier ministre
dans l'hémicycle ils ne sont que 28
députés a donné les orientations au pays
beaucoup font aussi partie de grandes
familles de politique d'entrepreneurs et
d'actionnaires
ce n'est pas un problème cette
concentration du pouvoir économique
politique et financier
je renverserait la question que doit-on
faire offrir nos participations et ceux
qui veulent peuvent acheter investir
tout le monde a la possibilité de
prospérer
il ne faut pas mettre l'accent sur la
concentration dans le froc et donne à
lire on est allé de l'avant tous
ensemble main dans la main c'est un
système politique qui a permis notre
survie
ce système fermé longtemps opaque a
séduit des investisseurs étrangers cinq
banques andorranes se partagent le
marché et plus d'une centaine de cabinet
de gestion gère tous les dossiers
et nous dire nous rien ce permis de
résidence il en est où
mais la regarde si la société est
inscrite
parce que le monsieur arrive la semaine
prochaine
manelphe lynch a créé son propre bureau
il accompagne 300 clients comme l'animal
je suis en train de gérer un permis de
séjour pour un ressortissant japonais
mais également un ressortissant marocain
tout le monde vient ici alors qu'il y a
quelques années c'était impensable
jamais un japonais n'aurait connu
l'andorre
[Musique]
ce qui les attire des opérations
désormais complètement transparente et
un système fiscal ultra avantageux
depuis 2018
on a arrêté de nous considérer comme un
paradis fiscal
comme on peut le voir sur ce tableau
l'impôt sur les sociétés est de 10%
nos voisins eux ont des taxes bien plus
élevé
quand on a une entreprise en andorre et
bien les dividendes sont exemptés
d'impôts
l'impôt sur le revenu est aussi très bas
avec un taux maximum de 10%
ce système extrêmement avantageux ne
fait pas la joie des pays voisins
notamment l'espagne me gallant réel
maillot est inspecteur du fisc espagnol
sa mission vérifier que les expatriés
fiscaux sont bien résidents en andorre
c'est là on est dans un des quartiers
les plus chers d'andorre c'est
intéressant car l'an dernier les
demandes pour une résidence dans le pays
ont bondi de 90%
les fortunes espagnoles achètent ces
villes à plusieurs millions d'euros
plus récemment ce sont des youtube art
espagnol qui ont posé leurs valises
le mailloux tumeur qui gagne 2 millions
d'euros ici il va payer à peine deux
cents mille euros combien père est-il en
espagne on a un taux d'imposition
maximum de 40 7% et donc en espagne ils
paieraient près d'un million d'euros
cette fiscalité a attiré le youtuber
espagnol le plus populaire elle rompt
bios 40 millions d'abonnés
le lido fernandez 7 millions de
followers est aussi séduit et il ne s'en
cache pas
et là on n'en dort on paie des impôts
mais honteux saigne pas comme en espagne
il ya des gens qui me disent est né en
espagne tu devrais payer des impôts en
espagne
alors
pour l'andorre la formule est parfaite
ce petit pays récupère les plus grandes
fortunes d'europe
concurrence et fiscalement l'andorre
pour n'importe lequel des 27 pays de
l'union européenne
c'est impossible c'est un tout petit
pays qui peut se permettre d'avoir un
taux d'imposition sur les sociétés de
10% un impôt sur le revenu de 10% et une
tva de 4,5 pour cent aucun pays de
l'union européenne ne pourrait survivre
avec ses impôts ils doivent faire face à
beaucoup d'autres dépenses
infrastructures dépenses sociales fait
les comptes on ne pourrait pas maintenir
un minimum d'état providence
à la fois exception économique et
exception politique l'andorre est un cas
à part sur le continent européen
une principauté figé dans le temps
[Musique]
et on se retrouve en plateau avec laura
cambo laura sion prend une carte
d'europe aujourd'hui il n'y a guère que
le vatican et malte à appliquer cette
interdiction de l'avortement quelles que
soient les circonstances andorre et ce
troisième pays est ce que ça peut
changer et bien a priori pas tout de
suite car il n'y a qu'un seul parti
politique une seule formation qui
souhaite mettre le sujet sur la table il
s'agit du parti socialiste qui est dans
l'opposition
donc autant vous dire que le sujet n'est
pas une priorité dans la principauté il
faut également préciser que depuis plus
de 30 ans personne n'a été condamné pour
pratiquer ou avoir recours à un
avortement il faut dire que en andorre
c'est le plus grand tabou l'avortement
il ya une pression pénale qui à
culpabiliser les femmes il également une
pression sociale qui est part importante
partout mais tout particulièrement en
andorre car c'est un territoire très
petit 80000 habitants et là bas presque
tout le monde se connaît alors vous vous
évoquez l'évêque d'urgell qui est l'un
des deux co princes et l'autre co prince
et donc le président français à travers
l'histoire au départ c'était c'était
évidemment les rois de france on voit
ici emmanuel macron portant les insignes
de coprince d'andorre quelle est la
position du président français sur cette
question de l'avortement en andorre eh
bien écoutez emmanuel macron à s'est
rendu en land art en 2019 et il a
répondu clairement à la question on voit
qu'il ne souhaite pas s'engager on peut
l'écouter en tant qu'homme et citoyens
j'ai toujours défendu
le droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps
en tant que président de la république
française élu par le peuple français
j'ai fait de l'égalité femmes hommes la
grande cause de mon quinquennat et des
lois sont passés en france sur ce sujet
mais je m'adresse à vous en tant que co
prince
garant de l'indépendance de votre nation
qui est l'une des plus vieilles
démocraties d'europe qui se rêve
pour dire à votre peuple ce qu'il est
bon de faire
vous qui démocratiquement choisissez vos
représentants qui on a passé les lois
alors on l'a entendu emmanuel macron
refusent très clairement de s'impliquer
dans la question même si techniquement
ce serait possible en son temps nicolas
sarkozy avait un pouce et l'andorre à
prendre des mesures pour ne plus être
considérés comme paradis fiscal peu
après des mesures ont été prises
immédiatement et depuis l'andorre n'est
plus sur la liste grise des paradis
fiscaux par le c2 donc le coprince
français peut avoir un pouvoir il faut
qu'ils volonté politique est là en
l'occurrence sur l'avortement il sent
que ça ne soit pas au rendez vous ça
fait merci beaucoup laura cambo merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette émission c'est
la fin de ce magazine on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur france 24
[Musique]